(dreamy music)
- There are articles all around the world
with pronouns like he, she, it, they.
A lot of people just are
not quite sure what I am.
And honestly, a little
mystery is kind of fun.
I'm Rain Dove, and I am a model, activist,
and general enjoyer of life.
(magical chiming)
(energetic funky dance music)
So, I model as both a male and a female,
or in both menswear and womenswear.
I worked as a male bartender.
I've worked as a fire fighter
for a while under a male persona.
I've done landscaping as male.
Oh, I did power-washing
for a while in Long Island!
(moves into mellow alternative music)
I feel like every day
that I do more modeling,
every day that I say
I'm not gonna stop doing
what I'm doing, it's another day
in which I'm representing a community
that isn't stopping what
they're doing either.
My mission is not to look fancy.
My mission is to show people
that they belong, that they are beautiful,
that they are handsome,
that they are attractive,
and that they deserve to be elevated.
(moves into spacey dance music)
It is hard to protect yourself
from being exploited and
turned into a gimmick
by designers who are trying something new
or trying to get a bang for their buck.
But at the same time, in a weird way,
I really want to be exploited.
I want somebody to say,
yeah, let's try a gimmick.
Because I want them to see
how wildly successful that gimmick is.
I want them to start putting
people that look like me
or people that are different
on the runway regularly.
I'm really hoping that people see
that I'm not a model, I'm a movement.
I'm a human and, like, that's it.